se isso está acontecendo com você pode
ser um alerta do seu corpo para
necessidade de ajustes na sua dieta
nesse caso a sugestão é aumentar a
ingestão de ácidos grassos do tipo
ômega-3 que são super importantes pra
saúde da pele o óleo de fígado de
bacalhau e o óleo de linhaça são ótimas
Fontes desses nutrientes e ao mesmo
tempo É aconselhável reduzir o consumo
de ácidos grassos do tipo omega6 que é
encontrado em vegetais comuns como soja
milho e canola lembre-se pessoal a nossa
pele é um reflexo de como está a nossa
saúde interna Então se perceberem a pele
descamando especialmente ressecada Pode
ser que falte ômega-3 na sua alimentação